le coc vide 19 qui perturbe le début
d'année scolaire depuis hier deux
classes sont fermées au groupe scolaire
les pépinières de voisins-le-bretonneux
l'une en maternelle l'autre en
élémentaire et décision prise par
l'éducation nationale et l' agence
régionale de santé après que deux
enfants aient été testés positifs au
coronavirus et les institutrices et
l'atsem des deux classes ont également
été placés à l'isolément
la municipalité a par ailleurs
communiqué aujourd'hui sur la fermeture
d'une troisième classe cette fois ci à
l'école maternelle des à quarante
arpents aux derniers chiffres remontant
à hier soir l'académie de versailles
recensait une école et 13 classes
fermées